hi so i studied neuroscience for two
years and i learned everything from the
brain from how to code them up to the
biology of the different neurons how to
do an fmri experiment from the beginning
but aside from these things i also
learned three lessons that i think can
benefit anyone so let's get straight
into it so the three lessons are related
to the three e's i would say so the
first one is the fallacy of expertise
the second one how to explain things and
the third one about experience so the
first thing i kind of want to talk about
is the fallacy of expertise and i think
when i went into the master of
neuroscience of computational
neuroscience which i did at the donors
institute in nightmare i kind of
expected that i would get better at
neuroscience and that i would learn more
and kind of feel more of an expert but
what i actually noticed after the two
years is that i actually felt i knew
less about the brain and i had more
questions than i ever had before and i
think that is because neuroscience is
such a young field and people come from
all different backgrounds so we had
students from biology physics
mathematics
and because you can then really see
where in your knowledge gaps lie you
really understand that there's just so
much more you can learn about the brain
and also so many different few types or
viewpoints you can have about the brain
so if you look at the brain from a
physics perspective you maybe think of
electrodes or a tiny electrical machine
you could think of entropy and chaos
theory or the theory of big numbers
whereas if you look at neuroscience from
a biology perspective you maybe would
think more in terms of hormones or the
tiny molecular cells that the brain is
made up of and i think combining all
these views into one field that is
called neuroscience is what makes it so
fun and so complex and the second thing
i learned is to really understand
something you need to be able to explain
it from scratch and also be able to
build it i think in a sense
so the brain is a really complex machine
and i think something i learned pretty
early on is the way to best understand
the brain is to try to build it yourself
and we do that in the lab by making
these type of computer visualizations so
we measure data from people's brains and
try to visualize them in a machine or we
measure different neurons with
electrodes that are put in the head and
then we can measure single electrodes
and i think by building a model that
acts similarly to how we measure these
signals that would for me really allow
me to understand what the brain is
actually doing so i think neuroscience
is one of the most
interesting engineering feats as well so
you can really understand the brain by
trying to think how can i make a brain
myself and the last lesson i learned is
if you really want to excel at
neuroscience it's really important to
get hands-on experience as soon as
possible so i came from a background of
physics theoretical physics to be
specific and in theoretical physics we
just think a lot so we just think a lot
about how things could work and then
make the mathematics about it but the
interesting thing with neuroscience is
you can apply almost the same models as
the models that are used in physics but
the reality will always be a little bit
different and this is because the amount
of variables that influence your brain
are just so vast that no model could
ever capture them and that's why i think
having hands-on experience as soon as
possible is super important so if you
want to learn more about animal brains
for example to get experience in an
animal research lab or if you want to
work with human participants to maybe
join an fmri study and i think
neuroscience is one of the fields where
you can really do this quite quickly as
opposed to some of the fields that are a
little bit more theoretical so these
were my three e's or things that i
learned during neuroscience and if
you're studying neuroscience at the
moment i would be interested as to what
your experience are so put them down in
the comments below and otherwise see you
next time bye